Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom contained some
pretty shocking revelations, but the 2018
sequel ended on a cliffhanger, leaving us
with more questions than answers.
We’ve done some digging, and we think we
know where the third installment might be
heading.
Here's everything we know about Jurassic World
3 so far.
In 2017, Colin Trevorrow was fired from Stars
Wars: The Rise of Skywalker over creative
differences, despite the fact that he’d
already dedicated two years of his life to
the project.
Lucasfilm came to the conclusion that Trevorrow
just wasn’t the right fit for Star Wars
and replaced him with J.J. Abrams, but when
it comes to the Jurassic movies, he's the
go-to guy.
Trevorrow only had one theatrical feature
on his resume when he was chosen to helm 2015’s
Jurassic World, his critically acclaimed time-travel
caper, Safety Not Guaranteed.
Despite a lack of blockbuster experience,
the director handled the summer tentpole like
a seasoned pro, impressing the man behind
the movie that started it all.
During an April 2018 interview with Entertainment
Weekly, Trevorrow revealed that Steven Spielberg
personally asked him to take charge of Jurassic
World 3, an offer that he simply couldn't
refuse.
"Steven Spielberg asked me [to direct], and
when he asks you, what can I tell you, man?
In all honesty, over my past few years, I've
grown to love and cherish the value of the
gift that I've been given with this franchise."
Interestingly, Trevorrow only came aboard
the franchise after J.A. Bayona turned down
the chance to direct Jurassic World.
Bayona took the reins for 2018 follow-up Jurassic
World: Fallen Kingdom, but Spielberg wanted
Trevorrow back in the hot seat for the all-important
third film, which is due for release in summer
2021.
Trevorrow is co-writing the picture with Pacific
Rim: Uprising’s Emily Carmichael, which
should make for a pretty interesting mix of
ideas.
“I just love the idea of a dinosaur biting
the head off a robot.”
“I love that too, so sweet.”
Colin Trevorrow has confirmed that the stars
of the first two Jurassic World movies will
be back in action for the third film.
Marvel man Chris Pratt returns as dinosaur
researcher Owen Grady, while Bryce Dallas
Howard reprises the role of former park operations
manager, Claire Dearing.
Speaking to Entertainment Weekly ahead of
Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom’s official
release, the director indicated that a number
of characters from the second movie could
end up playing a big role in Jurassic World
3.
Trevorrow said:
“There’s other characters who we’ll
meet in Fallen Kingdom you’ll realize are
major characters.”
Now that we’ve seen Jurassic World: Fallen
Kingdom, we think we know just who Trevorrow
was talking about.
Isabella Sermon will most likely be back as
Maisie Lockwood, the genetically-engineered
granddaughter of John Hammond's murdered business
associate, Benjamin Lockwood.
With nowhere else to go at the end of Fallen
Kingdom, Maisie rides off into the sunset
with Owen and Claire, who seemingly adopt
the cloned child as their own.
She basically sets up the entire premise of
Jurassic World 3 when she releases the cloned
dinosaurs.
“I had to.
They’re alive.
Like me.”
So, Maisie is bound to have a substantial
role in the upcoming sequel.
Daniella Pineda's dino-vet Zia Rodriguez and
Justice Smith's constantly terrified systems
analyst Franklin Webb...
...also escaped Isla Nublar with their lives,
so both characters could feasibly pop up in
Jurassic World 3.
The finer details of the plot are being kept
under wraps at Universal, but there's one
thing we know for sure about Jurassic World
3: the film won't feature any new hybrid dinosaurs.
Jurassic World introduced us to the Indominus
rex, a fifty-foot long killer that was created
from the DNA of several dinosaur species,
as well as tree frogs, cuttlefish, and pit
vipers for good measure.
The Indominus was designed to increase visitor
numbers at the park, but Jurassic World: Fallen
Kingdom's Indoraptor was created as a weapon
of war, a dinosaur that can attack on command.
This vicious new hybrid was still in its prototype
stage when it went to auction, which obviously
didn’t end well for the guys trying to sell
it.
While the designs are undeniably cool, the
introduction of these new dinosaurs took the
franchise into monster movie territory and
away from its science thriller roots.
Colin Trevorrow has revealed that he has plans
to go, quote, "back to basics" with Jurassic
World 3.
The director told Total Film magazine:
"I'm looking forward to, in the third film,
getting a little back into the [...] wild,
animal, true dinosaur nature of all of it.”
Could Sam Neill, Laura Dern and Jeff Goldblum
return as Alan Grant, Ellie Sattler and Ian
Malcolm in Jurassic World 3?
All three actors have reprised their respective
roles since debuting in Jurassic Park, but
they haven’t been in the same entry since
they appeared together in the franchise opener
back in 1993.
Goldblum popped up most recently, though his
part in Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom was
little more than a glorified cameo with one
really cool line.
“We’ve entered a new era.
Welcome to Jurassic World.”
Judging by the comments that Goldblum made
while he was a guest on Watch What Happens
Live in 2018, this contrived committee scene
won't be the last time we see Dr. Malcolm.
“There's going to be another one, which
some people may or may not be in.
That’s all I can say."
Goldblum had previously hinted that Laura
Dern might be getting back in her khakis for
Jurassic World 3, something the Star Wars
actress is clearly keen on.
When she spoke to Deadline in 2018, Dern said:
“It’s a good time for powerful, feminist
characters to be honored.
I love Ellie.
[...] I love her, and I love dinosaurs, and
there is something extraordinary about getting
to live out something that we all carry from
childhood.”
During a 2019 appearance on Good Morning America,
Dern was asked by none other than Bryce Dallas
Howard if she would consider returning to
the franchise, and her response made it sound
like she’s basically waiting to be asked.
“Do you know something I may not?
And two, if I were to, would you join me?”
“Hell yes!”
Bryce Dallas Howard has been pretty vocal
about her desire to work with the stars of
the original Jurassic Park movie.
The actress was quizzed about the chances
of them coming back for one last expedition
while she was promoting Elton John biopic,
Rocketman, and she seemed to indicate that
it was definitely in the pipeline . She said:
"I don't know what's been confirmed or whatever,
but I'll blink if it's happening."
The return of Neill, Dern and Goldblum would
tie the sequel trilogy to the original one,
and it would no-doubt go down well with the
franchise’s enthusiastic fanbase.
When MTV suggested that some people might
feel robbed if no legacy characters show up
in Jurassic World 3, Colin Trevorrow gave
an encouraging response.
The director said:
"I totally agree with that.
I would feel robbed, too."
The Jurassic World franchise is in need of
a new villain.
We've seen the last of the conniving Eli Mills,
who became a light snack for Rexy in Jurassic
World: Fallen Kingdom, and Vic Hoskins is
also history, ripped apart by a raptor towards
the end of Jurassic World.
That means there's going to be a brand new
villain in Jurassic World 3, but that doesn't
necessarily mean a brand new character.
Dr. Henry Wu is the man responsible for bringing
the dinosaurs back to life in franchise lore.
He was John Hammond's go-to geneticist in
Jurassic Park, and he continued his morally
ambiguous work in the sequel trilogy.
Wu survived the events of the first two Jurassic
World films, and there's a chance that he'll
go full villain in the trilogy closer.
Nerdist wants to see this happen, calling
for a, quote, "powerful resolution" for the
character.
"John Hammond's legacy is always present in
the Jurassic World films, but no living character
connects the new trilogy to the original film
like B.D.
Wong's Dr. Henry Wu.
He's the Walter White of Jurassic Park, which
is why he's now the most interesting character
in the franchise.
We have a history with Wu, we have questions
about how he got to this point, and we want
to see where it leads him — especially after
the end of Fallen Kingdom left all of humanity
at risk of extinction."
Colin Trevorrow has indicated that numerous
characters from Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom
will appear in Jurassic World 3, but what
about the supporting players from Jurassic
World?
Jake Johnson put in a scene-stealing performance
as Lowery Cruthers in the 2015 film, and the
news that he wouldn't be returning for Fallen
Kingdom was a blow for fans of the easy-going
control room worker.
When Trevorrow sat down for an interview with
Den of Geek, he explained why Johnson wasn’t
in the second Jurassic World movie, and at
the same time opened the door for his return
in the third one.
Trevorrow said:
"He's not in Jurassic World 2 for the same
reason that any other actor would be excluded
from a movie — unless we can find a genuine,
organic way to make it not seem like he's
just in it because he was a great character
in a previous film.
It doesn't mean he'll never be back, and I've
had conversations with almost all of the actors
going back to the previous films about how
important their legacies are to these movies
and [...] how important it is to continuously
change and evolve them into something new."
14 years passed between Jurassic Park 3 and
Jurassic World, but that long gap wasn't down
to a lack of trying.
Numerous sequels were reportedly floated during
that period, and the one that got closest
to getting the greenlight came by way of director
and screenwriter, John Sayles.
Sayles’ Jurassic Park 4 never got off the
ground, but what's interesting is that a lot
of his ideas ended up being used in Jurassic
World and Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom.
The star of Sayles’ story was an unemployed
mercenary named Nick Harris, who seems very
much like the blueprint for Chris Pratt's
ex-Navy man, Owen Grady.
Most notably, it was Sayles who came up with
the idea of shady types attempting to train
dinosaurs as weapons, which seems to be the
overarching theme of the Jurassic World movies.
If this unused screenplay influenced the first
and second Jurassic World films, it could
also contain clues about where the third one
is heading.
The Sayles script taps into the idea of an
America plagued by rogue dinosaurs.
With the country in crisis, humans weaponize
dinosaurs in an effort to stave off extinction.
Considering everything we’ve seen so far,
it isn’t hard to imagine Jurassic World
3 playing out along these lines.
He wouldn’t give an inch when it came to
plot details, but Jurassic World 3’s leading
man Chris Pratt said that the movie was definitely
going to deliver when he sat down with MTV's
Josh Horowitz in February 2019.
“I can’t say anything.
But I can tell you, when I heard the pitch,
I was blown away and I can’t believe that
we’re going to make that movie.”
The actor is clearly on board with whatever
it is that writer-director Colin Trevorrow
has planned, calling the story, quote, “pretty
epic.”
Pratt went on to say:
“I can't believe they found a way to deliver
on the promise of the end of Jurassic World:
Fallen Kingdom.
[...] The island has blown up.
The animals are out, we can't put them back
in the box.
What are we going to do?
How are not only these dinosaurs but this
technology moving forward going to affect
the planet?”
The co-star of the franchise also confirmed
that there would be a time jump between Fallen
Kingdom and Jurassic World 3,
“We jump forward, and it's like, 'Oh!
Oh, right!
Oh, damn!'"
giving further credence to the idea that Jurassic
World 3 will take place in an America overrun
with dinosaurs, the vision first put forward
by John Sayles.
This scenario means that Isabella Sermon's
Maisie Lockwood will be older and wiser than
the last time we saw her.
She freed the dinosaurs at the end of the
previous movie, will she take their side again
in Jurassic World 3?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more videos about Jurassic World
3 are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.